mais alors pourquoi toutes ces attaques
contre didier rahout est-ce qu'ils
dérangent les tons preuve d'acharnement
contre lui ou ses critiques sont elles
finalement justifié c'est ce que nous
allons tenter de comprendre pour en
parler nous sommes avec violaine guérin
médecin immunologiste endocrinologue
bonsoir violaine gerard est aussi co
fondatrice du collectif
laissons les médecins à prescrire
philippe froguel à vos côtés chercheur
en nonne endocrinologie également
biologie moléculaire et génétique vous
est également professeur à l'impérial
collège de londres et à l'université de
lille 2 bonsoir à vous aussi fini
progrès merci d'être avec nous alors
martin hirsch a des mots forts le patron
des hôpitaux de paris qui accuse
clairement le professeur raoul de faux
témoignages ça vous choque les progrès
oui c'est assez les dix huitième épisode
de délégués entre les mandats parisien
et didier raoult ce qui est un petit peu
triste c'est qu'ils ont convaincu le
directeur général de l'ap-hp hirsch à a2
en de se lancer dans la guerre avec des
informations qui sont fausses en fait
puisque c'est pas un faux témoignage
qu'elle fait un didier raoult il a donné
des informations qui sont vrais ou qui
sont fausses mais qui correspondent à
des choses qui ont été dites et filmé
par vos confrères de ces news ou de bfm
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure ces deux
informations bien été donnée à la fin du
mois de janvier elles sont peut-être
fausse mais c'est pas du faux témoignage
si ces gens se sont trompés à ce
moment-là bravoooo s'est trompé bon il a
le droit de se tromper mais ce qu'il a
dit a bien été annoncée montrée à la
télévision par dr lacombe
donc c'est beaucoup une tempête dans un
verre d'eau
même diagnostic alors c'est les femmes
aux chiffres on en parle 1 43 % de
mortalité en réanimation dans les
hôpitaux parisiens c'est ce qu'avait
justement repris le professeur raoul ce
sont des données effectivement qui
existe qui n'existe pas c'est une
tempête dans un verre d'eau
écoutez je partage
le même sentiment que mon collègue
premièrement parce que nous avons tous
entendu les témoignages à la télévision
de madame lacombe de monsieur comme et
de différentes personnes en plein milieu
de la crise où effectivement ces
chiffres et est annoncé donc ce sont
quand même des gens qui travaillent à
l'assistance publique de paris qui ont
donc a priori dit des choses exactes
et puis d'autre part bon c'est qu'en
général monsieur raoul ce document
plutôt assez bien ce qu'il raconte
je pense que vu l'état actuel de la
crise quand on prend des positions où
l'on fait ce type d'assertion sait de
quoi l'on parle en général parce que on
a bien compris qu'on était dans exposée
potentiellement à des suites juridiques
donc je pense que tout ce qui a été posé
et documentée
comment vous expliquez dans ce cas
philippe froguel la posture enfin la
posture je sais pas si on peut appeler
ça une posture d'ailleurs les propos de
martin hirsch est ce qu'il est dans son
rôle il fait son travail où ils
cherchent peut-être aussi à détourner
l'attention c'est que lui aussi a
beaucoup de problèmes sur les bras en ce
moment l'or noir thé riches a rappelons
le avait fait une conférence de presse
bidon sur un des médicaments dits
miracle à qui était un inhibiteur de
l'interleukine 6 et à cette conférence
de presse à a entraîné le conseil
scientifique de l'étude à démissionner
donc il à thème déjà des choses à se
reprocher à martin et je sais vraiment
pas pourquoi il s'est lancé dans cette
aventure totalement stupide qui le
dessert alors je ne sais pas s'il à
nîmes étaient manipulés ou si le coc
vide rend dingue est à peu près tout le
monde
mais là franchement les 2 de chris neil
et pour pas y arriver il se lance dans
un combat aussi douteux violaine guérin
effectivement vous c'est quoi votre
analyse sur c'est vrai qu'ils osent en
l'occurrence martin hirsch alors que lui
même voilà des problèmes gérer mon
analyse et qui se passe des choses tout
à fait anormal sur cette crise et
je pense qu'on n'a pas fini de
détricoter tout ce qui est en train de
se passer
il ya énormément de conflit d'intérêts
et c'est pas seulement au niveau
français qu'il faut le regarder je pense
que c'est une problématique mondiale
qu'il faut détricoter il y a des choses
totalement anormal pour la première fois
de ma vie j'ai été menacé parce que je
publiais un article sur le sujet en
l'occurrence et témoignant de
l'efficacité de des traitements en phase
précoce azithromycine seul ou
azithromycine plus hydroxy chloroquine
et je suis ravi de voir que hier on
vient d'apprendre que l'on a des
résultats à peu près comparable à ce que
tu as une publication américaine qui
vient de sortir
donc il se passe des choses surréaliste
parce qu'être en tant que chercheur
menacé par des institutions françaises
en l'occurrence est extrêmement
surprenant voilà donc je pense que vous
les journalistes
à chaque fois je vous le dis mais vous
avez fait du travail parce que nous on
reste assez centré sur le côté
scientifique bon je sais que monsieur
froguel a beaucoup communiqué sur la
problématique des tests là aussi c'est
totalement surréaliste qui s'est passé
donc voilà on est dans une problématique
très particulière philippe froguel
le conseil scientifique et la haute
autorité de santé a eu aussi sont sortis
du bois et se sont rangés un petit peu à
la vie de martin hirsch des propos
infamants de la calomnie
il faut dire que voilà le professeur out
on entend rarement aussi peu langue de
bois devant la commission de l'assemblée
nationale il a clairement évoqué des des
conflits d'intérêts et il faut forcément
se défendre on imagine que ça plaît
évidemment pas tout le monde hein ces
propos alors beaucoup de médecins voir
la plupart des médecins ce qu'on appelle
les leaders d'opinion ont des relations
avec les industriels du médicament est
donc effectivement une très grande part
de des gentils semences et comité a au
nom avoir des relations avec des
industriels ne veut pas dire d'avoir des
conflits d'intérêts vous exactement
avoir des conflits potentiels et ça veut
pas dire qu'ils sont vendus à ces
industriels donc moi je ne rentre pas du
tout à dans la discussion
this to ou accusant les personnes de ces
comités qui se sont posés à 86 croquis
en disant qu'ils sont payés par tel ou
tel laboratoire
j'ai par contre ce que je remarque avec
la haute autorité c'est que quand un
article de l'enset est sorti à la haute
autorité a donné tout dessus de santé a
donné tout de suite un avis défavorable
à la ligue roc cyclo routine alors
qu'elle n'avait pas eu papier donc moi
je me pose quand même des questions pas
vrai pas véritablement sur leur
honnêteté mais sera leurs compétences
scientifiques et en l'occurrence là ils
ont montré une très très grande à un
compétences scientifiques puisqu'ils ont
même pas sûr alors qu'ils ont soit
disant des défenses spécialisons pas ils
ont pas su voir que le monde sait que
cette étude était totalement trafiqués
et quelqu'un comme moi qui n'a
absolument aucune compétence dans ce
domaine si simplement à scientifique en
lisant un peu à petit j'ai été aperçu
mais s'est bien aperçu que c'était du
trafic et c'était la pire fraude
alors ces gens là quand même il faut
dire les papiers avant de les utiliser
pour interdire médicaments c'est avec
beaucoup de zones d'ombré sur ses
médicaments votre collectif violaine
guérin d'ailleurs c'était mieux dans un
communiqué lundi soir de ce blanc seing
je cite accordée par l'agencé européenne
du médicament hors md et vire comme
traitement de bucovine ça veut dire
concrètement quoique on est en train de
faire qu'on a fait une faveur à un
traitement dont l'efficacité n'était pas
nécessairement prouver que le terrain
écouter manger par le passé déposé
quelques dossiers des semaines donc je
sais exactement ce qu'il doit y avoir
dans le contenu comment les dossiers
doivent être analysées et donc on est
surtout surpris qu'il n'ait même au vu
de ce qui a été publié sur le sujet et
je suis d'accord avec vous un monsieur
problème pour dire ses idées théoriques
de complotisme c'est pas c'est ça c'est
un vaste mots je pense qu'il ya des
différents centres d'intérêts de
différentes industries pharmaceutiques
moi je prends une pas spécifiquement
guinée à do ou autre je pense que quand
une épidémie émergent c'est l'occasion
potentiellement ouvrir des nouveaux
marchés et c'est donc au niveau de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ça travaille
beaucoup en ce moment que ce soit sur
les vaccins et médicaments et tout est à
la limite pourquoi pas si on est dans
l'éthique le respect des patients et
cueillez pas de manipulation ou quoi que
ce soit aujourd'hui on sait non
seulement ému effectivement durée d'une
mêmes rapide sur le même désir mais
également ému sur le fait qu'il est
toujours impossible d'avoir des données
extrêmement clair sur la soi-disant
toxicité des docks cycle ans keane et
donc on demande à l'agencé la rfm les
des données claires et quand je dis
clair c'est avec la plus tabilité qu'ils
ont fait des soi-disant événements
indésirables et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
ces données
or normalement toutes ces données
devraient être accessibles à tous les
citoyens français
en tout cas un docteur n'est pas
d'accord avec vous il s'appelle laurent
alexandre vous me connaissez évidemment
vous avez déjà débattu ensemble
ici on va écouter laurent alexandre qui
était notre invité hier quand il s'est
avéré que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
n'était pas efficace
didier raoul tu pour noyer le poisson a
expliqué qu'il y avait un complot de
gilles ead pour contrer l'hydroxyde
chloroquine et émettent leurs md et vire
à la place en réalité c'est pas du tout
ce qui se passe puisque le désir n'est
pas prescrit donc il ya une crainte qui
a été montée en épingle par didier raoul
tu es si vous prenez les vidéos youtube
de didier raoul depuis quelques semaines
il y en a beaucoup qui sont consacrés à
gillet à ça lui permet de faire oublier
le fait que
même aux états unis où trump avait
beaucoup beaucoup poussé l'hydroxyde
chloroquine on l'a retiré des
médicaments autorisés dans le colis de
philippe froguel que vous inspirent ces
propos de laurent alexandre cécé didier
raoult et qui crée tout simplement la
polémique et la suspicion
ferrer didier raoult a sa propre opinion
et sa propre opinion c'est que ses
collègues qui sont contre doxi plan qui
ne le sont pas ce qu'ils ont des
conflits d'intérêts bon c'est pas mon
opinion
en général quand on hésite entre
complotisme machiavélisme à et j'irai
chaos et bêtise c'est souvent la bêtise
qu'ils arrêtent et responsable moi je
suis pas je suis pas impressionné par le
niveau scientifique des différents
comités de delfraissy ou par les autres
j'ai bien vu ce que ces bêtises qu'ils
ont sortis pour les élections
municipales le premier tour
on les appelait autorisant ce qu'ils ont
fait pour les tests sur les marqueurs
je pense que le vrai problème c'est les
compétences et l'utilité de ces deux
comités la façon dont ils ont été
utilisés par les politiques souvent pour
répéter ce que ce que voulaient les
politiques pour hydroxy chloroquine
j'aurais bien aimé qu'elle soit beaucoup
plus efficace qu'elle ne l'est c'est
tout ça est bien triste parce qu'on
réalité on n'a aucun aucun traitement
miraculeux antiviral actuellement
violaine guerre le mot de la fin parce
que ce qui est mis en cause
effectivement c'est c'est ce que dit le
professeur à alltel en rose
on se pose la question tout simplement
est ce que c'est vrai qu'on était mieux
soigné à marseille qu'à paris est ce que
marseille a eu des des meilleurs
résultats je pose une question difficile
mais c'est la question finalement assez
central moi ce que je vais vous dire
j'ai mon expérience puisque j'ai soigné
des patients avec ce protocole et quand
on avait plus de claquer need avec
l'azithromycine seul donc j'ai mon
expérience de terrain parce que monsieur
enfin que ce soit monsieur alexandre où
de nombreuses personnes qui prennent la
parole non pas à soigner un seul patient
qu'ovide donc mangé mon expérience
clinique je suis médecin libéral donc j
patients présents maman je les ai pas
vus au stade d'hospitalisation donc mon
expérience et que les résultats sont
extrêmement intéressants
voilà en phase précoce moi je n'ai pas
travaillé en réanimation
donc c'est important aussi de donner la
parole aux gens qui ont pris en charge
des patients fait philippe froguel le
mot de la fin
votre vue justement sort je pense que le
bilan de didier raoult est pas si
mauvais que ça puisque il a proposé
quelque chose à des personnes qui
étaient en hausse avec une angoisse
terrible qui ont souffert pendant des
semaines tout seul a délaissé par tout
le monde puisque à lacets à l'époque
qu'on leur disait de ne pas voir de
médecin et d'appeler le 15 que si
vraiment il allait mal sans diagnostic
et didier raoult a fait des tests et
sage
je suis extrêmement reconnaissant ce qui
fait les gens savaient ce qu'ils avaient
on a ont été suivis et on leur a donné
de les occire chloroquine ça a servi de
ça pas servi ça a pas eu d'effets
secondaires graves
il a respecté les contre indications et
on fait faire des électrocardiogrammes
je ne sais pas si ça a été efficace mais
ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut être
empathique quand on est médecin et que
tant les gens souffrent
il faut les prendre en charge et à la
gloire qu'à marseille les gens n'ont pas
été pris en charge au départ de rome
elle a dit merci à tous les deux
philippe froguel lionel guérin d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france